bienvenue à paroles autochtone si ces
médicaments alain dupuis cette semaine
j'ai aussi une question de valérie qui
ne demandent que pensent les autochtones
des mouvements nationalistes question
une patate chaude que tu me donnes entre
les mains parce que c'est très difficile
d'en parler il faut pas oublier que
depuis justement les dernières
tentatives du vote de la séparation du
québec un des enjeux qui avait été mis
de l'avant pourquoi la séparation
pourrait pas avoir lu c'était la
séparation était même pas été discuté
avec les premières nations donc on peut
pas aller de l'avant sans penser même
aux droits ancestraux que les
autochtones on est malheureusement
jusqu'à cette période là les discussions
se faisaient uniquement entre les
communautés il fédéral
donc il est de plus en plus un
développement je pense par rapport au
discours par rapport à intégrer les
communautés dans le discours
nationaliste dans le discours
séparatiste selon quel angle on veut
prendre par rapport de nationalisme je
pense que c'est très divisés par rapport
à la direction qu'on veut prendre vers
ce discours là mais je dirais qu'il ya
deux mouvements qui sont quand même très
déterminé très claire dans ce que je
vois présentement il ya un mouvement que
beaucoup modifier son discours pour
inclure les premières nations et souvent
malheureusement ce discours là peut être
intolérant à d'autres citoyens c'est à
dire des citoyens des nouveaux arrivants
des gens qui sont liés à l'immigration
des réfugiés alors on va on va souvent
c'est d'opposer les deux communautés de
meylan parle même pas des droits
d'octobre puis on peut aller sauver tout
le monde dans les autres pays parce que
justement au tibet on est attaquant on
est tous autochtone c'est-à-dire qu'on
essaie d fois d'instrumentaliser
l'identité autochtone pour son pouvoir
politique c'est à dire en clamant nous
racines autochtones
on devient des autochtones donc on a des
droits ancestraux donc on a des droits
la séparation du québec pas là et
finalement ça devient de
l'instrumentalisation des enjeux et des
droits autochtones
c'est très difficile parce que c'est
souvent basés dans un discours très
bienveillant mais on voit que le
résultat est prêt
et très égoïste le deuxième mouvement
que j'ai vu est beaucoup plus
intéressant pour moi c'est à dire les
gens veulent discuter mais si on faisait
la séparation puisqu'avec qu'est ce que
ça voudrait dire pour les pros nation
est ce qu'on pourrait faire ça ensemble
est ce que ça pourrait des choses qui se
voit comment on pensera un pays entre
nation et là tu vois un discours
beaucoup plus ouverts à vouloir
transformer les réponses plutôt que
devoir nous instrumentaliser et je sais
qu'il n'ya pas longtemps même ghislain
picard avait dit moi je suis un
séparatisme et pour les autochtones et
le mont a ouais on n'a pas pensé à cet
angle mais c'était j'ai trouvé cette
très le fun parce que s'il est ce qu'on
parle de d'enjeux de territoire savez
peut-être de se séparer tant que de dire
qu'on a des droits nous aussi sur le
territoire et ça veut souvent être
utilisée pour protéger le territoire
pour défendre les droits ancestraux et
non pas dans une division physique du
pays est vraiment dans une séparation
des responsabilités par rapport à la
protection du territoire
donc ça amène des discussions beaucoup
plus intéressante à ce point à ce point
de vue là alors tu peux comprendre que
entre les deux mon coeur balance d'un
côté beaucoup plus ouvert que d'un côté
beaucoup plus je dirais utilitaires et
je pense que la discussion un peu plus
maintenant être évité et c'est ce qui
rend la conversation nationaliste
intéressante mais je me méfie de l'autre
conversation nationaliste qui et
excluante et ça je pense que c'est une
opinion qui t'aiment assez partagé aussi
avec les autres communautés
j'espère y avons répondu mais si tu
comprends que c'est un enjeu qui va être
de revenir et qui vont être discutés
encore plus quand on va parler de
protection du territoire
n'hésitez pas à partager une vidéo
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer vos
questions justement à paroles autochtone
je souhaite une bonne semaine